okay so strategies for me development
and uh making sure not to just give
anything away for
yep and center opening up the center
quickly so
uh go knight f3
oh [ __ ] oh my god i'm terrible holy [ __ ]
whatever this happens every time i play
you too
god this guy's a gm what a joke
boom complete fraud of a title i bought
my title in
in the himalayas oh that's disgusting
daniel
unbelievable all right
[Music]
this tripped i got i already got
stripped of the title
okay
yeah they doubled your pawns uh oh look
at me
you know i don't like when that happens
daniel i think you should resign just
like
that guy in my chess club in san
francisco who would resign when he got
doubled pawns
he was the pizza shop owner he was 1700.
i think i told you about him
perhaps yeah i mean you mean forgotten
you've gotten this this incredibly
colorful character there were so
i could write a book about the
characters at the mechanics institute
chess club in san francisco
oh that place is hopping yeah that would
be a real page turner i'll tell you what
and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i've seen on that club
you will not believe
i've seen fights break out people
jumping on tables
oh outrageous
this is a camp what i'm trying to do is
i'm doing the ragoza approach
the rugosin approach is named after
a guy whose last name was rogozin
shocker he was a grand master he was
also the coach
of soviet world champion mikhail
botmanic and when he was preparing
botvanick for
his matches with his opponent uh his
opponent was known to be very
distracting at the board
so he would you know he would wear
sunglasses he'd make all these faces you
know he was one of those
people and this was tall of course he
was also a really really nice person in
real life
and so batman constructed his coach to
do
all sorts of things to distract him
during a game such as smoke cigarettes
in his face
this was back and was allowed to smoke
during the game
jump on the tables break stuff and the
goal was for bob nick to maintain his
concentration
and uh that's exactly what i'm trying to
do here
you're supposed to say how great of a
story that was and how great of a coach
i am
yeah no no that's exactly what i was
about to say too i believe that
then we can maintain our relationship
okay i'm in a castle
you know i'm always there for you i
don't like that
that fake scared of my attack tone
we'll see we'll see how scared of my
attack you are on three moves
i'm playing it real careful here on this
side he's playing decently but he's he's
not open up the center enough and i'm
gonna try to start attacking him on that
g file
okay good move
your attack is [ __ ] terrifying jesus
christ
let's check back in five moves i think
you're gonna be crying in the corner
i'm gonna prepare my own counter attack
i like it
i like i like the move c4 actually thank
you for opening up my bishop
i'm not worried about that so
hypothetically if i were to go g5 to
pawn to g4 here what would you do
pawn to g4 yeah which i'm not going to
do
i would push my pawn to h4 yep excellent
the umbrella method so that's why i'm
going to do here
i'm going to mess you up right now it
was a trick question
i just got some intel you know
what if i do something real wacky and
let you have that bishop
while i attack your bishop on the other
side damn girl
now i like the language you're talking
in
what if i was crazy enough to do that
daniel what if
i have no comment
now you got to do it you can't just
advertise that and then i get excited
and then you just take that away from me
i can't do it daniel it's too [ __ ]
scary
it'll be okay it'll be okay i promise
like every movie ever made
it'll be gay you've trained for this all
your life
if this was anyone else i'd be acting
much quicker daniel but because it's a
grand master i'm really trying to
ease all my pieces are oozing grand
masterdom
they move in ways that regular people's
pieces can't even dream it all comes
down to this move
this is the biggest moment of your chess
career
you know beating xqc was
close behind but this moment really
takes the cake yeah
was child's play compared to what we're
doing here i think i know what i want to
do daniel
i've heard that one before i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna i'm gonna trust my
[ __ ] gut on this one but uh
we'll see we'll see what this does for
me i suppose the truth is that is a
really good move
the truth is a really good move because
by taking my bishop
you're opening up the b file for your
rook which is a total disaster for me
so that is uh some progress some serious
progress
i'm not giving you [ __ ] you're gonna
have to
take that bishop over my dead body no
daniel
you're so close now you're so far
i was so close
but what if i told you i planned for
this would you believe me
i would say my ass
it's all part of the plan
it's like me blundering a queen over the
board and then pretending to keep a
straight face
when in my mind i'm like breaking every
object in
the nearest 50 miles i'm just i'm going
wild daniel
i'm getting wacky yeah you are actually
okay all right you think i'm just giving
you my bishop like that
that's actually uh maybe that's not what
i'm thinking after all our time together
that's who you take me for
no maybe that's not what i was thinking
at all daniel
what if this
this devastating move was my plan
i've i'm dead queen beef i mean this
this will call for immediate resignation
now get the [ __ ] out of my
out of my grill
gonna take on b7 uh i'm thinking about
it
what if i did what if you did yeah what
if i did huh
yeah try me you're gonna you're gonna
fight me
i'm not just i'm just i'm gonna take
your queen i won't have to fight you'll
be crying in the corner
before i've thrown my first punch
you missed that i can just sense it the
silence is so
telling that's not what happened at all
daniel
you led with your queen that's not what
i did
you're gonna see why this move is so
good pretty soon enlighten me
just wait i have a whole plan in mind
here queen
v2 that is the most aggressive move i've
ever seen okay
i'm taking that damn bishop i'm tired of
playing okay
c4 you should have played that move a
little bit earlier by the way
yeah i think instead of bringing my
queen i should have played that the
second i moved
now now we can keep fighting
it's it's like those like old russian
okay
i i assume you would know the reference
those old russian movies where there
would be fight scenes
but they would like do a sword fight for
five minutes then they'd both
like drink half a bottle of wine
together and then they would resume the
sword fight
[Music]
i think i've got a good plan here daniel
i've heard that one many times man
you're just very generous today
i heard buffets were closed ready hmm so
i wonder what your threat is here
maybe you're trying to take my pawn on
v7
nope that's not it what's up jam house
i ain't giving you [ __ ]
well that didn't work at all night a7
amazing move
now i'm curious if you you have a move
that wins and i'm curious if you can
find it
you you have a move that wins the game
basically
it it despite the fact that you're
losing your name
see even after all the abuse i've taken
i'm still there for you
i mean i only have one actual useful
move which is to bring the knight back
to c6
but then i take it so you want to bring
my king out to a vulnerable square
that's what i was looking at okay but
you have a queen in your rook on the b
file so what's what's on your wish list
like
what do you want to do with that queen
in the rook why in what
circumstance would they become the
strongest they could be
if they were uh through that pawn on b6
so that's exactly what you want to do
now
in order to do that you need to use what
another pawn
that's the language i like to hear oh
bingo
if i did so if we ran through that and i
did bring your king out into
c6 would that not work because what i
was looking at is then i
deliver a check at d6 well then you just
go back
you mean pawn to d5 yeah yeah and again
you got to be careful about assuming
that i'm just going to take all your
pawns
and i might but i'm going to go here i'm
going to try to be stubborn keep the
position closed
now you're moving if you know what
you're like aiming for here the move
should be automatic
yeah i think i still have to deliver
this check by pushing this pawn
what remember what you want to
accomplish what specifically did
why did you play this you didn't do that
i would have
been at your front door in like five
seconds i would have reactivated the
concorde
you know that [ __ ] plane i you know
you you too [ __ ] old daniel i don't
know nice
supersonic jet
now if you don't find this move
that medieval museum i visited a museum
of medieval torture devices when i was
in the czech republic
i might we might have to pay a visit
there together i think i
uh i don't see any counter play if i
know if i was to play this pawn move
first it doesn't work if i deliver the
check first you have an escape square
all but look at
all checks all directions don't limit
yourself
i'm looking to one-sided bingo
so when you have the king wide open like
this that is the moment at which tunnel
vision is at its
most i know you can give a check on v8
that's still me but you want to force
yourself to look at all sides of the
board
thanks john for the raid how would it be
mate though if i deliver that check you
go to d7
well made in a couple i'll show you i'll
show you how i would have gone about
mating if i'd [ __ ] up like that
um let me invite you to work but overall
despite all the trash talk
i don't think i've recovered from that
but i'm gonna give you a begrudging
compliment there that was better than
the previous odds games we played
good good good good okay
so a couple of things and i'm going to
nitpick here because you know
tournaments coming up
knight c3 was fine and here
i wouldn't waste any time opening up the
center
now what do i need by the way yep and
what if i give you this check
uh i block with bishop yeah very good
and yeah rocco's next time for sure
you gave away this bishop and some of
these light squares if i had a queen
this would have been a bad position for
you
right because these light squares would
have been kind of weak
okay so here here you did everything
perfectly well and i'm actually pretty
[ __ ]
proud that you play this move this is
this is some growth right here so if i
take in the bishop can you
spell out exactly what you do i push
that f3
okay do you need to do that i take back
what i just said
not right away i can take your bishop
first take my bishop i
take and that actually plays into your
hands what can you do oh i just take and
that opens up the file for me
go ahead okay so then i do this
and it gives me this yep and um
you're just completely crushing
so instead bishop b4 queen e2 is great
now in this position queenie ii was a
good move attacking the bishop
my bishop is basically toast how can you
finish it off
i should have played this first yeah c4
i take the bishop
so i take this yeah and i can take give
you a meaningless check
uh i take with the rook here right right
and by the way let's say i played g4
like let's say i try to distract your
attention it takes me so many moves to
create [ __ ] that now you can do what you
wanted to do previously which is what
which you did previously now you can
take this pawn but you can involve your
queen and where can you put it
um
why not would that still be fine i mean
then you just push it up and we're in
the same position from last time
okay but you can't compare like that the
situation is different completely
because the ship's gone because the
bishop's gone here you're not actually
attacking the pawn and when you
have an attack against the king remember
this is a good move because it leaves
behind
weak squares and you can now occupy
those weak squares with your pieces so
what do i mean which squares have been
weakened
as a result of that move yeah right now
we have c6 open pawn's no longer
defending it
exactly so you can squeeze in what piece
there
looks like knight would be better there
i think i would even consider queen c6
because if you take on a5 you open up
the b
file something you can immediately
exploit
with one move what's the fastest and i
want you to bring this all the way to
checkmate
um let's see we can bring the queen back
to a8 that gives you only one retreat
retreat square
it does but right now the queen's doing
a great job of limiting the king and
basically preventing it from going not
every the move doesn't have to be a
check
this is the situation where you're
working for rooks that's good but i can
still try
to intercept you um it's it's a move
with this rook
bring it into the game threaten
checkmate
oh i just bring it to the i bring it
here i bring it over to b7 instead
and now that i've deactivated the bishop
you can mate with what
sequence there's many ways to mate here
by the way
it's pushing this pawn first it's a good
move and then you can develop
deliver upon me you can also stack the
rooks
you can also play rook takes a seven
with what idea
uh oh bringing it
um if i let's say i make a random move
like white's a play mate and
we're just bringing this yep so how do i
see all of this
i start by looking at the final what
final position do i want what is the
mating
position you can also go d6 and you can
trust your intuition here you don't have
to always find the most
efficient approach as long as you're
moving in the right direction so here
you went queen b2 c4
f3 now in this position again you
reacted automatically
and this is really one of the biggest
takeaways from today is
in a situation like this this is where a
lot of blunders will happen in pog jams
people will assume that you have to
recapture a piece but look at this
carefully what else can you do
i can just immediately take bishop's
gone yeah so go ahead
yeah b7 i can just immediately start
doing that and now
you don't want to let the king escape
anywhere so you can do what
another intermediate move it's bringing
the
queen no like that doesn't stop that um
stop me from going like this way you see
what you want to prevent
yeah i think it it is this right because
that's gonna stop you from accessing
yeah
and now you gotta collect the [ __ ]
yeah
and this is the same [ __ ] yeah yeah
so now you don't want to take this to
like a crazy level
and every single moment that some piece
is captured you take
15 minutes to consider intermediate
moves but in these situations
the king is weak when there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on
when a piece when your opponent takes
one of your pieces
sometimes they'll leave a fork exposed
oftentimes you'll see a queen blundered
in that way let's say there's a queen on
d a king of b
you get what i'm saying right bishop was
defending that square they take your
rook
and they leave open the possibility of
some sort of fork so you want to check
for that
consciously and uh other than that
the rest of the game was pretty i mean
knight a7 was it took uh
only you would play such a move but it
worked out in the end
so uh what would i do here i would play
c5 immediately
and actually the hilarious thing is here
i would play knight a7 check
and uh you see so i was just thinking
too far ahead for this right
you were so your wisdom i mean you your
brain couldn't catch up with the wisdom
of your thoughts and ideas
but c5 makes sense right yeah last thing
does it make sense that okay so try to
mate me here
i just want you to see this yeah what i
was thinking is starting here
and then when you take with your pawn i
take again that for that's going to move
your king
you still it's the hardest and this is
the biggest misconception people
think that the center of the board is
the easiest spot to make the king it's
the opposite it's the corner
where the king is at its most confined
it's very hard to give
actual mate here you can i'm sure with
the right sequence of checks
but even i struggle with these kinds of
things
okay that makes sense so i i really want
you to be careful about that and be
careful about assuming that i have to
capture i can come back and yeah
yeah okay so c5 takes takes
checkmate and if i'd given a check on v8
where would the mate be well what i
would think is okay let me look at all
of the possible checks i can give a
check on b5 but i just came from there
are there any other logical checks
the only other check is a pawn check and
what would this accomplish and i'm
thinking well if the king takes on c6
that's what you wanted to do
earlier and there's a maiden one there
with what
uh king takes there i just dropped the
bishop
the queen back yeah and if king e7 made
in two
this is your chance to finish that's
going
yeah it's going c8 and d7 right yeah but
what can you do that in a forced way
oh take on c7 you're so magnetic you
don't want to take my pawns you don't
want to hurt my feelings
i get it that's what it is
yep windy summit is made and guinea of
course is the faster mate so overall
that was really good
just a couple of these minor
modifications right knight a5 was great
and
if you're up a queen like against code
meek or something you don't want to give
away pieces for no reason but if
you can give away like a bishop uh to
open up
the king as you did and to facilitate
your attacking task that's pretty much a
no-brainer
what you want to be really careful about
is giving up too much right
saying ah let me give up a queen for a
rook to simplify my task now let me give
up another bishop
to trade another piece like you want to
draw the line very carefully so you're
still
up a lot of material okay that makes
sense perfect
so i think that was good we'll do
another one of these games tomorrow what
do you say we finish with
one more game in the pool sure
fantastic and then tomorrow we'll focus
on on the vienna we'll do some more
tactics and
maybe we'll do a little bit of prep
sounds good to me
fantastic
wow your opponent's already stopped
jesus oh we get to go right into the
vienna
indeed
okay yeah a lot of people play this move
and you actually play f4 anyway here
i'll teach you this tomorrow yeah i
analyzed this today with one of my
students
okay now
uh be very careful what is he
threatening uh bringing the queen in
so as an autumn as a point of view yeah
exactly
and then his bishop on c5 is incredibly
misplaced it allows you
to do what
i can occupy the center a bit further
yeah with tempo
with well not e5 but oh i'm sorry d4
that's what you meant that yeah that was
the one i meant right exactly of course
and that attacks the bishop occupies
what else does it do what okay
continue in these positions do i want to
use the bishop just bring bishop over d2
or do i want to immediately
you don't give a [ __ ] about the pin
because as i you're your pawn is
defending the night so
let him take your knight i don't give a
[ __ ] about those double pawns
focus instead on recovering the pawn and
developing your king side quickly
okay so uh i'm taking pawn first and the
white square bishop right
exactly you can also develop the light
square bishop first you don't have to
recover the pawn
immediately and see uh people are
obsessed with this double pawns but look
at he's not developed anything
and now where should you develop your
light squared bishop
uh i can bring it over to d3 do you need
to defend that e4 pawn i know you're
looking at it but look at his
development do you really care about him
taking that e4 pawn
intuitively no i guess no it's not a
good position for the bishop
it's not a good position for the bishop
and it opens the e file so develop the
bishop as if he wasn't a tag in the pawn
okay so in that case i'd bring it over
to c4 yes
my guess is he's going to take the pawn
in about
five seconds he's going to be like oh
[ __ ] this idiot blunted upon
okay that was wrong what do you do
i castle now yeah hopefully he takes
upon the queen that'll be even worse
yeah pins the queen to the king okay now
he's
really asking for it so this is now i'm
pushing this pawn right yes
he's got an id5 he's got a good
retrading square but then
that paves the way for more moves with
tempo
so he's attacking your bishop where
should you move it i just bring it back
to g2 or g3 y
passive and you're blundering a fork on
e3
he's got a queen on e7 that queen is
misplaced
uh uh i just want to attack the queen
yep
i see and also do you see that the
knight could have gone to e3 and
delivered a fork dear queen in your rook
knights in the center equal check for
forks oh
that helps you out quite a bit
uh so he has weakened his light squares
in front of the king here
yes but also his queen is on e7 his king
is on e8
what does that entail that means there's
an x right here i can bring my rook to
e1
now or or or like in a what do you have
to do first
uh do i have to i have to take first
yeah you have a damn pony if i get it
out of the way
and that another thing that's automatic
now you've gotten a lot better at
observing things like that but yeah
and he can only block with his bishop
and that's a very flimsy cover
let's see what he does
can he play knight e4 walk with his
knight
no i think there's a way his queen
designed so okay but you're not getting
off the off the hook because i wouldn't
have resigned against you
um before i let you before i let you go
um this is an important teachable moment
i'm inviting you to an analysis board
just when you thought you were off the
hook
so if i had gone bishop before how do
you actually
win the game how do you win this bishop
so what initially stuck out to me is
just bringing my bishop back but then
when you take my well you can't take my
bishop
yeah but the problem with that is that
he can defend it with a pawn yeah
so you're on the right track but you've
got to ask
the bishop is fulfilling a very
important role it is preventing his pawn
from coming to d5
like let's let's say you make a random
woman he plays d5 what do you do
um
i just take yeah and because of the two
pins he can't take the bishop
so can you assign the task of pressuring
this bishop to another piece
yeah i was trying to see if there was a
good knight move to accomplish that
look at the retreating moves too yeah is
it just d2 then
that's all there is this move looks yeah
like what what are you doing but that's
the beauty of chess you know this move
is
you know earth shattering because he
can't do anything if he like he can't
even castle
and if he plays knight c6 which piece
should you take the knight with
i take it with the rook yeah that's a
pretty elegant move you could take it
with a knife but this also wins this
queen because of the pin
you could also play bishop d5 yourself
although this would be inaccurate
because remember queens
are that's not the only piece on the
board you want to make sure that when
you're winning your opponent's queen
you're not giving him a bunch of pieces
and returns what would black do here
he'd probably push a pawn yeah but then
you take his bishop
how does he get the most for his queen
oh he just takes on uh
yeah and he gets a rook and a piece for
the queen white is winning but knight d2
is better because it will win either a
full piece
or a queen and a piece or more
so retreating moves and applying logic i
want to attack this bishop but i don't
want to allow d5
let me look at all of the pieces and see
which ones can actually put pressure on
the bishop very nice
but look at how the vienna is is working
so how do you feel that felt pretty good
uh
in the beginning um playing
c4 f4 no no no uh
like after this okay i see why you want
to play f4
oh bishop c4 yeah uh i was going to
protect that hanging pawn
as opposed to going to c4 oh so what
would have happened if he'd taken it
yeah so there's i'll give you two
answers um
what i would have done here as white is
bishop takes f7 check and i want you to
tell me the follow-up to this
you've seen this you've seen this time
type of tactic a million times
yeah this is delivering another check at
g5 with the knight
yep now we're taking the bishop now
you've recovered your pawn more
importantly the king cannot castle let
me try to win one when you're
in your bush now be careful white to
move
you have only one way to defend don't
you dare blunder anything
can't move the bishop hangs the knight
can't move the nair hangs the bishop
uh can't block with the queen to protect
them
i just pushed the pawn i'm good yeah
yeah
i was i was about to [ __ ] explode
yeah so that would have been
one way but here's the other thing um
you can just castle and what i want you
to understand is that
you have developed all of your pieces
black has developed one
black's king is stuck in the center i'm
not calculating a single variation
i don't need to calculate to know that
your development advantage
far supersedes this miserable pawn that
he's captured
and also you've got the possibility of
pinning him anyone
does that sort of make sense from a
general standpoint yeah
so again i'm not telling you if you're
not comfortable giving up upon this is
perfectly fine bishop d3 is a good move
but you shouldn't let pawns confine you
and always assume that you have to
defend upon that mentality and you can
use that against your opponents
right you can attack one of their pawns
and you can be pretty sure that they're
going to automatically defend it because
that's just a mistake a lot of people
make but pawns are
in the middle game one of the lesser
important pri or less important
priorities
and we'll we'll definitely delve more
into the theory of this tomorrow
because he's got some tricky moves in
this position you got to know he can
take your knight actually
and white is much better here but you've
got to know the line
okay so playing f4 right away the idea
is to occupy the center right
well the idea of the vienna in general
is and you only don't play four against
knight c6 you know that you play bishop
c
yeah yeah and you've done that well the
idea before is to dislodge the
pawn from e5 so that later you can play
d4 and as you said occupy the center
also to open up the f-file
which may seem absurd with white's king
on e1 but once you castle
that f-file could offer the artery
through which you can attack life's game
okay so that's that's the sort of bottom
line now if he gives you a check on h4
last thing
how do you respond to this here just
because you took so long finding this
move
you're just pushing the pawn here yeah
sending the queen but and
queen f6 send the queen back even
further
uh this is something you always look at
when you have a queen on f6 in the
opening
yeah i'm looking for d5 here with the
knight that's not even necessarily the
best move but i just wanted you to
notice it
so anyways we'll talk about that more
tomorrow but we've done a lot
um and i know it's late so i want to let
everything sink in
uh how do you feel any last any
questions from today anything you wanted
to review
um let's see i feel like i had a
question for the dragon but i can't
remember it now
it and it was in the okay and it was in
the main line like after d4
because in the block champs you're
definitely going to see some of this
you might see some of this i remember
what it was it was uh when they
i'll flip the board here in black it was
uh
when they developed bishop here i play
this
and then it's uh from here it's knight
f6 and then i push d5 right
yeah depending on what but if they
castle and go rookie one you actually
take on e4
why is that so how do you follow up why
is this not blundering a piece
oh it gives this fork yes bishop d5
you can't take with a pawn but you take
with the queen remember now you've got
you've garnered the light squared bishop
so you can actually go queen to d7
just so the queen defends everything and
then you can fianchetto the bishop and
you've got a beautiful diagonal here
um and the reason that you don't go d5
here
is because you would love to take with a
pawn but you can't you would have to
take with the knight here that's just a
tad
awkward okay okay
so and if they go d3 why do you go d5
here or not there
like what's the difference all right now
there's no rook
so we're doing this we can take and you
can and which piece of bishop do you
want to develop first what's the
priority here
so this is this is good because
typically uh
what i'll end up doing is pushing one of
these pawns before developing and i
think that's
wrong right i want to do bishops now god
forbid because when you push this pawn
look at what diagonal always check what
changes what do you give your opponent
okay yeah you're you're busted here
so you absolutely have to prioritize the
king side bishop b7
castle like the good russian school boy
that you are and then you can develop
this bishop
don't you dare play that move in my
presence again just kidding
why did you play d forticurus did you
want to stop him from developing his
knight
yeah it was mainly just to cut off the
knight i get it
but the purpose of these pawns in
general is that they they basically
blunt
a lot of his pieces and that's why
that's why this is a bad setup for white
because you get pawns in the center and
these pawns in the center
curb the you know limit the
effectiveness of his pieces the last
thing
is in a position like this where do you
want this bishop on cnn this is a case
where you actually don't want to give
away upon you do want your bishop to
occupy a defensive role
okay so then we're planting it on e6
then bingo and then you have this idea
of expanding on the queen side with a6
and b5 and then trying to trap the
bishop with c4
yeah so i find a lot in the accelerated
dragon i use a lot of
pawn moves is that yeah is that okay
that's normal
totally normal as long as you are still
prioritizing
principles developing your pieces
castling not combining e6 and g6
and uh one other thing that we're going
to work on tomorrow
with a couple of exercises is positions
where it's not clear how to attack
i also want you to be comfortable making
general improving moves like let's say
let's say you couldn't play a6 what
would you do if you just wanted to
slightly improve black's position
my rooks are inactive so i'd look for
somewhere to plant
them let's see what's a good active
square
i guess uh b7 would be kind of nice for
that rook right because then i can look
for maybe a pawn break up top
oh you mean like b8 or b8 sorry
definitely
and i would also if you wanted to play
less creatively you could play queen d7
and then this is a very classic position
your rooks in the center b d8 and e8
okay right so when you're like i don't
know what the [ __ ] to do
you go back and you pull out your bank
of just improvements can i connect my
rooks can i bring my rooks into the
center
can i move my king and make it a little
bit safer and i want to make you a
little bit more comfortable it's not
always about
you know crazy attacks and you're going
to encounter situations in the poc
champs where it's important not to
freeze
and in order not to freeze you've got to
always remember that in most positions
you can make those general improving
moves
okay um i want to chase that bishop away
on g5
uh it's i would say it's a good idea to
play chicks because a lot of people are
going to take and that's a bad idea
because that gives you a brilliant
beautiful bishop here
definitely play this move early i would
play it here
the only circumstance when you would be
cautious about playing this move is if
your opponent has a queen on d2
that's a battery which means you have to
reckon with what move
like what can and i'm not saying this is
good for white but you have to calculate
it because it could be dangerous
uh he takes i take and then he delivers
a check
um he takes back yeah and you know your
king is weak you got to move your knight
back and bring your bishop into the
defense
um so that would be something which
would
make you think twice and you don't want
to do it here
why not
i have a hanging piece of d5 so you can
take your knife yeah exactly so it's all
about the
top priority is to make sure your center
is protected then i would play h6 and
then you would improve your position
so in the dragon is the center more
important here to make sure that we have
all the
the pieces in the center defended yes
that's the that's priority number one
then i would say priority number two is
this idea of a6 b5 once you feel like
you're ready and priority number three
is if we're like for example if your
opponent goes a4
to stop b5 then you can start improving
your position by bringing your pieces in
and then consider
central breaks like c4 or your favorite
d4 at some point
okay so but i think you have a good
sense of it
and you shouldn't overthink it like if
you feel like a move is healthy and good
you should play it just be very careful
about when you haven't castled yet if
you're making a move that doesn't help
you castle
you should have a very good reason for
it
so that would be the bottom line does
that help a little bit yep
that makes sense and we'll talk more
about that for sure so
okay this game a better one we're gonna
watch one more and then i'm gonna i'm
gonna start playing
come on charlie get it together
you're better than this
nice just don't remove this yep and is
his opponent gonna miss this again
no he's gonna probably play knight c3
yeah i'm just gonna play bishop c4
charlie's gonna probably go here no
knight f6 yeah
now his opponent might go here and that
would concern me
castles
yep knight h5 is the best move charlie's
going to take though i'm
we're very worried about that
okay prove me wrong boy
there we go i think we went over this we
went over this idea
very nice very nice
time for some more tea i'll be right
back
take the bishop men and take the pawn
with your bishop
take the pawn with your bishop come on
probably considering this move no i
think he looks good
playing playing ideally here
i think when he gets a good position out
of the opening like that's what really
is the x factor in a lot of his games
i mean this is an obvious move
okay now see this charlie's probably
gonna go here
but d5 would be the best move
that's how you know you've been coaching
someone for a long time
now he's probably going to go here
although i would move the queen but
that would be it okay fair enough
well it's just i understand his
tendencies i not all the time but i in
most positions i understand how he's
going to think
it's it's nothing to do with me being
anything i'm just
you know you work with someone a long
time you know how they're going to think
about a position and not in a bad way
it's a
kind of good yep so he wants to open the
bishop which is great
he certainly doesn't play passive moves
i completely disagree i don't think
that's one of his weaknesses actually
it used to be but not anymore
bishop takes nine
i'm mostly guessing wrong i mean i think
i'm at about 50
now is he gonna see the night
okay why is he thinking jesus christ if
he doesn't okay great
yeah okay it's just right he's just
crushing this guy completely
yeah just move the bishop you can move
it to d4 also
it's resignable but let's see how he
converts it
let's see whether he can convert it
smoothly
i hope white resigns but i don't think
he will i mean
yeah so if i were charlie i would
consider e6
um i don't know what he's gonna do here
actually
he might move the queen somewhere thank
you white grizzly for the tier one
yeah d5 i was gonna say maybe this
i just hope he doesn't go e5 and traps
his own bishop
this will be tempting for him i think
let's see what he does
i would bring my queen up to d6 and
actually threaten to take on g3
potentially
maybe he'll notice the discover shotgun
with his bishop again
one of the mistakes that he's made
sometimes is to threaten something just
to threaten it
a threat isn't good just because it's a
threat threat has to accomplish
something
okay i'm not um you know occasionally i
can
i can get it yep
alex morris thank you
50 50. no i'm not pretending to be more
than 50
i don't know i have no idea what he's
going to do here i i think he's going to
move his queen up
but if i had to guess but i'm i'm
probably going to be wrong
wanna tally another one for me fractal
cadence
okay that was easy he was gotta add a
move division back
it's going to push his pawn up
which would be correct by the way
he's probably thinking about this would
be my guess
in this i think these are the two things
that he notices here queen c6 is one to
build the battery
he's also noticing these pawns pushing i
think he might do that
yep
the problem is i can drop to f3
okay i didn't really guess it my guess
would be e5
maybe he'll move the rook i don't really
don't know
no he's not going to go f5 yeah so i got
it in the wrong order
yeah now e5 is best he's playing this
phenomenally e5
e5 oh my god okay white panic just take
take it quickly quickly
yes
this would be a nice move i'm just
worried charlie likes to attack the
queen with pawns
when he sees a queen his first tendency
is to attack it with a pawn
but i would bring the queen over to g6
let's see if he can find this move
one of his limiting limiting things
is or he'll see this and push the pawn
up like he's too narrow in this thing
he's up two bishops god damn it
move move charlie come on stop
overthinking it
this i mean come on look at your clock
jesus christ
it just freezes he freezes forgets about
his clock rookie yay
again he's def okay we need to we need
to work on that like seriously he's
making the same mistake
now he's going to freak out again and
he's going to bring his queen back to d7
or something
or bring the other rook up to f7
he's gonna try to take this so h6 would
be the best move here i think he'll see
that
he has to understand that the queen has
to make has to be moved and he's gonna
lose on time simply
he's up to bishop yep
take the rook take the queen charlie
come on take the queen see it
yes yes yes okay great
too slow
okay one more shall we watch one more
he's playing at 1100.
okay knight c66 you'll know he knows not
castle's knight f6
okay d5
why is he thinking we went over this a
million times
i i don't know why he's thinking there's
no reason to think
he needs to play d5 and there we go but
still too slow
yeah i know i know i know i'm just
taking it hard on him
okay bring the bishop out like we talked
about priority number one is to develop
the king side
we literally just talked about this
exact position
and uh i know charlie likes to do this
charlie loves to pin the knight and i
get it
okay this is fine okay this is fine you
can you but this is a little too
committal
right you first want to develop your
king's side so bishop e7 here is very
important
castle his opponent wants to take
okay now charlie wants to go here okay
would be a good move
x-ray also likes to go h6 in these
positions but
um d4 yeah that's okay we need to d4 is
something else it does
okay he'll probably probably take that
and this is a good move but
well the problem with d4 is that it
again he's confusing
he thinks this is a good move just
because it attacks the knight
that's not how chess works you can't
just say it's a good move because it
attacks knight it weakens a bunch of
squares
it gives the knight a really nice square
in the center and there's no point in
doing that
your pawns are perfectly good in the
center
okay there's just no need to to do this
there's no redeeming factors yeah he
does
d5 although he he understands the
concept of occupying a square left
behind
i mean this will be his instinct i think
but taking on e4 will be the best move
okay knight c5
okay it takes
i'm just going to put a rook on it
yeah lots of these habits that are very
easy to break actually
okay he'll also see this move
he likes it i mean queen g6 would be a
good move actually
but i'm sure he's looking at this
probably
i like this a little bit less than queen
g6 because the queen might be
susceptible to an attack
now rookie 8 probably will follow um
but yeah okay rook this rook to you
now he likes rook lifting in these
situations now a very good move in this
position
would be f5 in order to limit the
mobility of the knight the knight on d2
you always want to look where does that
want to go well it wants to go to e4 it
wants to centralize itself so you want
to take away that square
from the knight thank you imo summers
for the front
another great move would be to slide the
rook into e3 that's a very i'm sorry
it's a weak square that was created as a
result of f3
it goes rookie seven not rookie six well
he'd say yeah he'll on bassan and double
the rooks he wants to double which is
interesting
because then you can go rookie two yes
i'm harsh on him but
i want him to learn these concepts right
oh what is this
this is what is this move just dc
it's tough love i know what he's capable
of and when he performs
below that expectation or ability i'm
the same way i'm with myself which is
you know oh it's gonna be all right
you'll get a medal for just playing like
that's not how i work
can't can't go against my nature
i've seen whiplash but that's that's
obviously the extreme end
i i've seen it many times were you
rushing or were you dragging
takes takes come on take on c4
projecting yes exactly what i'm doing
being just as toxic to him as i am to
myself
well i'm not telling what mentality
others should have but
i think there's a middle ground okay he
should double his rooks
but he goes to e2 which is great
yeah it's a crazy movie i mean that's
just crazy that's way too
too that's that's just a borderline
abuse but
i've had coaches that have been on all
ends of the spectrum
okay what i would try to do is i would
get the now charlie might see this pawn
and take it
because he takes okay but look at that
he sees it rook v8 rook v2
looks to the second ring rook b2 nice
he's threatening mate
he's threatening mate rook takes so
let's say white does something random
this bishop on c4 blocks the king's
escape so the rooks work together in
perfect synergy with the bishop
can't stop it he can give just a useless
check does he see it
this is a mating pattern charlie
struggles with those
why do you suppose i threw a chair in
your head newman
crazy i mean the stuff he sees now is
awesome just awesome
i think it's pretty natural yeah check
checkmate it's not not too difficult
all right pause chimp piggy's on the
seventh i think that's how
i'm called
if he misses this that doesn't help
check checkmate come on charlie
take the damn pawn first you take the
pawn then you think
now he's got to understand that the
bishop cuts up
yes there we go beating at 1100
beating at 1100
i just wrote him
yes this is good this is a very good
sign
it's another great accelerated dragon
game some mistakes i mean he lost the
threat in the middle game
but he recovered i mean active pieces
he saw the hang pawn rook ba was just
awesome this is like growth right here
not to take the pawn not to defend the
pawn but to
understand that his rook needs to go to
b2 is awesome
that's just awesome he's good with white
too we just need to work on the vienna
[Music]